a dream come true spice calcio we're
going back on tour Emma Bunton dishes on
the Spice Girls reunion tour
I just left London with Mel I did I
talked to her about her book shoes she
was so much fun she was over the moon
excited about this tour so can you give
me one little secret about the Spice
Girls tour in what we're gonna see okay
well we were together just the other day
back in London and and we're at the
stage now where we're creating so we're
creating the stage we are talking about
the setlist and and I think we love that
but we sit together like what code you
know what the outfits gonna be so that's
where we're at at the moment she told me
she was gonna get the original wild Mel
B hair I want to see that back what are
we gonna do what are you gonna do Wow I
you know I did a bit of pink for the
shoot and I thought it's kind of no
touching baby but also bit modern so
yeah I love it
now you know there's another Baker
celebrity Baker that is the biggest
Spice Girls fan Chrissy Teigen
oh because she loves you guys I know
yeah so you guys have something uncommon
Adele has been going crazy or getting
back together
Emma stones going crazy that you guys
are getting back together could there be
like let's pull a celebrity on stage and
do a number with us kind of thing on the
tour
[Music]
really really good um so okay I think
that this this could be a way to get
Victoria back on stage bake her
something have one of the contestants
Baker's something yeah what's her
favorite little dish do you know she
likes blueberry so maybe we could do
like a blueberry crumble busy bees
better I'd have to get one on consistent
state though because I am I couldn't I'd
get lost but I can help me maybe are you
kind of bummed that she won't be there
I'm still hoping I'm still holding out
you know what it's so lovely because the
the support that we give each other
anyway night she's been emailing and we
chat and and she's come to the show so
um you know the four of us feel very
strong now as a team so it should be
watching yeah it'd be nice over there
the door is not the only thing Emma's
got cookin up the singer is now the new
host of the great American baking show
holiday edition new host
ladies and gentlemen involved in all of
oh my goodness well I got I got the call
and I just felt like all my dreams had
come true
what are you a baker laughs um I try
with my children I do try but you know
how it doesn't matter because I've got a
good palate there you go we're glad
you're I'm a good eater there you go
there you do the baking I do the tasting
and it's great that's how the whole
thing works out what do you what do you
do well when you try with your kids at
home well we do cupcakes and funding
yeah I think being on this show watching
some of the contestants they're
incredible yeah they've got ideas coming
out of there like it's just amazing when
they say like do a showstopper some of
the stuff that these folks come up with
blows my mind because everyone's amateur
bakers exactly the amateur and oh I love
it when they've made these incredible
you know cake cakes and they come down
and can see they're walking towards Paul
and they're just like Oh
and also some of them a bit sloppy yeah
are they gonna fall I mean it's quite
tent show and I think you'll see some of
that you know the the tents in in the
first in the first episodes okay I need
to test you I need you to say one thing
for me okay I need you to say sunny just
so I can hear if it brings the ear right
okay well I'm hoping that your cakes
will not have a sub e bottom why do you
think people like me and in general
audiences are so obsessed with this show
because we love food we love take we
love pull Hollywood we love sherry I
think it's just and it's got such a warm
feel about it and it's Christmas and
it's a holiday edition so it's extra
special for me I mean it was again a
dream like eating cake being around
Christmastime just perfect and then of
course amazing judges with Sherry Yard
who are she's new to the show and I
great we just love each other I like the
fact that they brought some and she's a
pastry chef right I need somebody to be
able to rival Paul okay oh yeah but he's
never looked Paul in the eyes
[Laughter]
frightening off the baking competition
show premieres December 6th on ABC
[Music]
you